for the new addition to your family
megan said she wanted to wait until you
were here
to tell us is it a boy or is it a girl
you can tell her my good friend no no
let's go
during meghan markle and prince harry's
sit down with oprah winfrey
the couple revealed that they are
expecting a baby girl this summer
and meg she already has a sweet keepsake
to gift her little one
we've got our family we've got you know
the four of us and our two dogs and
yeah it's great in a 2015 interview with
hello magazine
megan was asked about a piece of jewelry
that has special meaning to her
and the former suits star revealed that
it's a watch
she wants to give to her daughter one
day i've always coveted the cartier
french tank watch
when i found out suits had been picked
up for our third season
which at the time felt like such a
milestone i totally
splurged and bought the two-tone version
you know nobody likes
nobody likes to show off meg went on to
share the special inscription she had
engraved on the back of the accessory
2mm
from mm quote and i plan to give it to
my daughter one day
that's what makes pieces special the
connection you have to them
in september 2013 megan was photographed
wearing her cartier watch at the canter
fitzgerald and bgc partners
annual charity day the price tag on that
fancy watch
a whopping 6 900
this year has been crazy for everybody
but to have outdoor space where i can go
for walks with archie and we can go for
walks as a family and with the dogs and
maybe go to hikes or go you know down to
the beach which is so close
as the duke and duchess of sussex
anxiously await the arrival of their
baby girl
they have their hands full with their
adorable one-year-old son
archie who is already talking the
highlight for me
is sticking him on the back of the
bicycle
in his little baby seat and take him on
these bike rides or something which i
never
i was able to do when i was young i can
see him on the back
and he's got his arms out and he's like
whoa chatting chatting chatting again
palm tree
house and all this sort of stuff yep we
learned baby archie has a pretty
impressive
vocabulary oh my gosh she's on a roll
i mean in the past couple weeks it has
been hydrate which is just but also
whenever anyone leaves the house he's
like drive safe
drive safe
you